سابقه في تاريخ تركيا الاتراك يعودون
لصناديق الاقتراع لخوض جوله الاعاده
للانتخابات الرئاسيه بعد فشل الجوله
الاولى في حسب المعركه السباق الرئاسي
اختزل في اسمين الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان
ومنافسه مرشح المعارضه كماله
اما المرشح الثالث سنان اوغان فلم يكن له
نصيب كبير من اصوات الناخبين وحسم قراره
بدعم اردوغان اردوغان في الجوله الاولى
كان على بعد امتار قليله عن فتره رئاسيه
ثالثه بواقع 49 ونصف في المئه من اصوات
الناخبين لكنه فشل بفارق ضئيل في تحقيق
الاغلبيه المطلقه البالغه 50% من الاصوات
زائدا صوتا واحدا فقط حيث تمكن اردوغان من
نيل اصوات اكثر من 27 مليون ناخب بفارق
اكثر من مليونين ونصف المليون صوت عن
منافسه كالجدار اوغلو في الجوله الثانيه
يعول المرشحان على المدن الكبرى لكن
اردوغان قدم اداء قويا في المناطق الريفيه
والمحافظات الداخليه والوسطى في الجوله
الاولى لكن نتيجه اردوغان في المدن الكبرى
التي تعد مفاتيح الفوز قلبت الموازين وجره
البلاد لجوله ثانيه من اهمها اسطنبول قلب
تركيا الاقتصاديه والعاصمه انقره ذات
الدلالات الرمزيه للنظام اداؤوا اردوغان
كان متراجعا بالمقارنه مع منافسه في
اسطنبول حيث حصل على
46.7% اما في انقره فنال 46% من الاصوات
مفاجاه الجوله الاولى الاكبر كانت في
مناطق الزلزال فيها تايم مثلا تساوى
اردوغان وكلو بنحو 48% لكل منهما لكن
اردوغان تفوق بفارغ كبير في قهرمان مرعش
بواحد وسبعين فاصله 9% وغازي عنتاب
الواقعي
59.8
المفتاح الرئيسي لنجاح اردوغان في الجوله
الاولى كان قدرته على اقناع الناخبين بان
الانتخابات لا تتعلق بالوضع الاقتصادي
وانما بهويه البلاد وامنها وكانت الارقام
خيره ترجمه لاداء اردوغان القوي والمخيبي
لتوقعات المعارضه بزواله السياسي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات